es sollte eine romantische geste werden
jetzt entwickelt sich aus der aktion von
zwei bundeswehrangehörigen ermittlungen
wegen des möglichen verstoßes gegen das
luftverkehrsgesetz im tiefflug fliegen
sie nämlich mit ihrem hubschrauber über
ein dorf im sauerland werfen dort ein
weißes paket ab dass eine frau
einsammelt angeblicher inhalt blumen für
die verlobte dirk becker beobachtet und
recherchiert in dem falle der sehr
kurios anmutet auf den ersten blick auf
den zweiten ist es dann schon etwas
ernsthafter mit solch einem hubschrauber
so eine aktion durchzuführen
dirk wie sind denn die ermittlungs
stände bei dir
und ja die ermittlungen laufen derzeit
die bundeswehr bestätigt auch einen
derartigen vorfall
wir stehen also hier direkt an der
pferdekoppel über die die hubschrauber
es war ein hubschrauber der sar meine
rettungsflieger die stationiert sind
dürfen nicht bei köln
der offenbar hier über diese gruppen
hinweg geflogen ist
während des überflugs am montag 9 uhr 30
befanden sich auf der koppel auf mehrere
oldenburger stute die trächtig sind wir
haben die pferde eben selber noch sehen
können bevor sie rein geholt worden sind
eine dieser studien hat auch tatsächlich
ein fohlen verloren wir hatten noch kurz
gelegenheit mit der halterin und
besitzerinnen affäre sprechen zu können
die den hubschrauber auch selber gesehen
hat wie eigentlich nokia etwa hin zwei
bis zweieinhalb drei metern etwa über
die wiese geflogen ist die sagt sie
könne zwar nicht behaupten dass ist dass
das pferd sein fohlen verloren hätte
aufgrund dieses überflug ist aber es ist
eben auch sehr wahrscheinlich weil die
pferde sind fluchttiere und sind dabei
in panik geraten von daher stößt also
dieser liebes einsatz des
hubschrauberpiloten hier in holzen einem
kleinen aus dem sauerland in der nähe
von arnsberg mit etwa 2000 einwohnern
eher auf unverständnis als denn auf
verständnis
anwohner berichten dass der hubschrauber
also wirklich mehrere anwohner dass der
hubschrauber in extremen tiefflug hier
über die wiese geflogen ist und dieses
paket auch abgeworfen hat bei dem inhalt
soll es sich dann wohl auch um blumen
gehandelt haben
das wurde aber offiziell noch nicht
bestätigt und ermittlungen gegen zwei
insassen des hubschraubers laufen wohl
es ist ein 44 jähriger der aus arnsberg
kommt und den piloten den man aber wohl
erst noch ermitteln muss und zu
laufenden ermittlungen machte die
polizei beziehungsweise auf die
bundeswehr derzeit keine angaben